-Even as
the Russia investigation
reportedly nears
its first possible indictment
of a Trump associate,
the GOP is insisting
on ramming through
a radical plan
to repeal Obamacare
without even waiting
to find out what it does.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Of course,
with everything else going on,
Trump has also
been preoccupied lately
with the North Korean
nuclear program.
And since it seems
like threats and sanctions
have not stopped North Korean
leader Kim Jong-Un so far,
Trump is trying out
a new tactic -- nicknames.
Over the weekend, he tweeted...
And then today,
he repeated the nickname,
not in a tweet,
but in his first speech
to the United Nations
General Assembly.
-The United States has
great strength and patience,
but if it is forced to defend
itself or its allies,
we will have no choice
but to totally destroy
North Korea.
Rocket Man is on
a suicide mission for himself
and for his regime.
-Why are you calling him
Rocket Man?
That's not a diss.
That's a cool nickname.
[ Laughter ]
You're making him sound like
a character from "Top Gun."
[ As Trump ] Hey.
Hey, Rocket Man,
you're on a suicide mission,
and there's only one way
to settle this --
on the volleyball court.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] So Trump --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump is again threatening
North Korea with military force
even though that seems to have
failed as a strategy so far.
In fact, as we know,
Trump loves
talking about the military.
He's surrounded himself
with generals,
called for massive increases
in military spending,
and during a meeting
with French President
Emmanuel Macron yesterday,
Trump talked
about how much he loved
France's Bastille Day
military parade
and suggested he might want
to replicate it
here in the U.S.
on the 4th of July.
Trump talks about the military
like a kid who just got home
from his first air show.
[ As Trump ] We had a lot
of planes going overhead
and one of them did a flip
and another one made a boom,
and then when we landed,
one of the pilots,
he tossed me his sunglasses,
and he said,
"Hey, kid,
I'll see you in the skies."
And then I said,
"Thanks, Rocket Man."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
[ Normal voice ] Of course,
it might be a little foolhardy
to make plans for next July,
considering the speed with which
the Russia investigation
is engulfing
Trump's White House.
Yesterday
was yet another bombshell
about the Russia investigation
being conducted
by special counsel
Robert Mueller,
suggesting that Mueller
may be close to indicting
one of Trump's
closest associates,
his former campaign chief,
Paul Manafort.
-Breaking news tonight
on special counsel
Robert Mueller's case
against Paul Manafort.
According to The New York Times,
when federal agents executed
a search warrant on Manafort's
Virginia home two months ago,
which was reported
more recently,
the special counsel followed up
with a warning.
His prosecutors told Manafort
they planned to indict him.
-"They even photographed
the expensive suits
in his closet."
-That's right.
They photographed
his expensive suits.
Well, Manafort might
like to shop at Armani,
but where he's headed
is definitely more
of a men's warehouse.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Now, the hard-nosed tactics
being used by Mueller
have been described by some
as a shock and awe approach
with one former
independent counsel saying
Mueller's approach
is intended to scare people
into telling him the truth.
And if there's anyone
who can strike terror
in the hearts of people
in Washington,
it's Robert Mueller.
Look at him.
He looks like the door-knocker
on a haunted castle.
[ Laughter ]
Another former prosecutor said
the investigation resembled
the way law enforcement has
historically gone after the mob,
telling the Times...
And that is so unfair.
How dare anyone call
the Trump administration
organized!
[ Laughter ]
They're basically --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on.
"Organized."
They're basically running
the government like a Roomba.
"Yeah, we just go
until we hit a wall
and then go somewhere else,
and we suck the whole time."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, with
the Russia investigation
escalating rapidly,
how is the president's
legal team responding?
Well, yesterday,
The New York Times reported
that there are
internal divisions
between Trump's lawyers
over how much to cooperate
with the special counsel.
Trump's lawyer, Ty Cobb,
has accused the White House
counsel Don McGahn,
together known as
"Franklin and 'Stache,"
of withholding
sensitive information
from the rest of the team.
According to the Times,
Cobb said of McGahn...
The craziest part, though,
is how The New York Times
found out about Cobb's comments.
It wasn't from an interview
or an anonymous source.
Instead...
The Trump administration
is worried about leaks,
and yet, it keeps hiring people
who are the physical
manifestation of leaks.
When they talk,
it should just be the sound
of air escaping a balloon.
[ Air hissing,
balloon screeching ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Now, obviously,
we don't know yet
where the Russia investigation
will lead,
but one thing's for sure.
It will continue
to infuriate Trump,
who remains obsessed
with both the 2016 election
and, in particular,
Hillary Clinton,
so much so that he retweeted
a video from a fan account
over the weekend
that made it look like
he hit Hillary
in the back with a golf ball.
Hey man,
I don't know if you noticed,
but you're the one
under FBI investigation
with approval ratings
in the low 30s.
If you're gonna post memes
of yourself golfing,
at least make them
more accurate.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
And, yet...
he was so happy to swallow --
he's so happy to eat
a golf ball.
[ Laughter ]
And yet,
even with these scandals
swirling around a historically
unpopular president,
Trump's party is still trying
to push through
his domestic agenda,
specifically his promise
to repeal and replace Obamacare.
The GOP is like your friend
who knows only one song
on the guitar
and he's drunk
and no one wants to hear it,
but he's tuning it up again.
Republicans are pushing a new
bill that is in many ways
even more radical
than previous bills.
The new bill...
Although last week,
when Trump first heard about
the new GOP health care bill
being advanced in the Senate,
he talked about it
in vague terms and made clear
he had no idea what it was.
-We'll be discussing probably
a little bit of health care,
because I know some
information's come to light.
-"Some information's come
to light."
Every time Trump talks
about health care,
he sounds like a teaser trailer
for a soap opera.
Next week
on an all new "Trumpcare"...
-We had to go
with the health care first,
and we're doing well.
I think we're gonna have
some great surprises.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-What kind of surprises?
This latest attempt to ram
through a health care bill
that would literally take money
away from vulnerable people
without letting people know
what it would do
is why Democrats need
to be extremely careful
before making any deals
with Trump and the GOP.
Trump has apparently
commented recently
that it's much easier
to get along
with Democratic leaders
Chuck Schumer and Nancy Pelosi
than with GOP leaders
Paul Ryan and Mitch McConnell.
According to Politico,
Trump has dismissed Ryan as...
Oh, I wish I could see Trump
trying to make small talk
with Mitch McConnell.
[ As Trump ]
Do you have a gold apartment?
[ As McConnell ]
I do not, Mr. President.
[ As Trump ] Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Why does your face
look like that?
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Meanwhile, after a meeting
between Trump and Schumer,
his fellow New Yorker,
a congressman who was present
said Trump and Schumer
got along so well...
...and Schumer was caught
on a hot mic on the Senate floor
gushing about how much
Trump likes the Democrats
and him, in particular,
even telling a colleague
that his new partnership
with Trump would go smoothly.
-No!
It won't work out!
He'll only be your ally as long
as you're useful to him.
Haven't you seen how he treats
his friends?
First, you'll stand behind him
at a press conference,
and the next thing you know,
you're eating nachos
and yelling at people
at baseball games.
It's a precipitous ball.
Remember, this is still
the same Donald Trump
who ran a cruel,
bigoted campaign,
who called Mexicans rapists,
bragged about committing
sexual assault,
and fired the FBI director
for investigating
his administration.
In fact, just last week
after an attack
on the London Underground,
before any details were known,
Trump doubled down on his call
for a Muslim travel ban.
-Trump tweeting...
-And then there was this.
-"Must be proactive and nasty"?
That's not a terrorism strategy.
That's a Prince "B" side.
[ Laughter ]
You know what,
can we actually hear
a little "Proactive and Nasty"?
-♪ I'm not gonna wait
for that ass to come to me ♪
♪ Unh ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ I'm about to get
proactive and nasty ♪
-That's it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, one of Trump's
closest associates
is on the verge
of being indicted,
and the GOP is trying
to ram through
a massively unpopular bill
that could strip health care
away from millions.
I'll say it again.
Donald Trump is really hitting
a hole in one.
[ Laughter ]
Right into his own mouth.
This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪